[Musique]
mais pour cet autre espace autochtone en
direct aujourd'hui on s'intéresse au
travail des autochtones pour un non pas
des autochtones et des architectes pour
répondre aux besoins des autochtones et
de leur environnement bâti mais aussi à
bâtir alors beaucoup de monde autour de
la table je commence à vous les
présenter tout de suite maya cousineau
molunes bonjour je veux qu elle vous
travaillé pour la firme d'architecturé
voc depuis un an et demi environ comme
conseillère en développement
communautaire pour les premières nations
et les inuit et on va expliquer votre
rôle vital heures également roxanne
gauthier vous aussi vous êtes celle
évoquant tant qu architecte exact depuis
13 ans maintenant
depuis 13 ans aux oies dont vous avez
fait beaucoup de choses oui oui charles
barker robertson dojo de foix
et puis ellis queen vent gens avec qui
on parle m'a parlé d'une exposition
aujourd'hui très intéressante qui
concerne les inuit mais qui a lieu à
saguenay
oui on va parler d'eux les oeuvres les
artistes et comment toute cette arrivée
de être saguenay en ce moment voilà
alors parlons des des architectes les
architectes autochtones y en a pas
beaucoup
je voyais que sur à peu près dix mille
architectes enregistré au canada il y en
aurait 18 au nom donne on se retrouve
dans l'ouest canadien
il y en a quelques-uns dans l'ouest où
il ya des glaces cardyn rhumerie est
bien connue qui est originaire de
calgary et à etienne gaboury qui lui est
un métis de l'ouest qui a beaucoup
transformé le paysage des prairies j'ai
vu qu'il y avait aussi une femme la
première fin des premières nations à
être architecte elle s'appelle luanda
attendez je mette mes lunettes ouanda
dalla costa elle est originaire de la
nation crie de sado lake en alberta
donc il y en a très peu chez évoque s
qui on a des architectes autochtone
architectes non en elle par contre des
technologues et des techniciens qui ont
travaillé avec nous oui l'un des
architectes pas encore mais on le
souhaite ardemment
alors on parle de évoque parce que
évoque s'intéresse beaucoup au bâti chez
les autochtones et bâti beaucoup de
choses chez les autochtones présenté moi
c'est quoi évoque moi comment qu'on m'a
présenté évoque en fait quand on m'a
approché pour travailler avec eux j'ai
appris que l'on en fait ça fait plus de
40 ans qui travaille avec les premières
nations et les innu
un des fondateurs monsieur n'est fournie
ça a été comme une passion une passion
pour l'art mais par la suite une passion
pour connaître les gens et se
rencontrent par la suite qu'il y avait
un besoin criant d'améliorer
l'architecte retour dans les communautés
donc on pourrait parler de la vision des
voc alors à partir de ça de tout à fait
la vision d box et farine architecture
dans le fond qui qui ressemble aux gens
auxquels elle est destinée
donc on travaille beaucoup en faisant de
la consultation que la collaboration
avec les communautés dans lesquelles on
travaille
oui ça me petit peu sur notre vision
notre vision qui est partagé par tout le
monde l'a vue de l'équipe c'est hausse
et c'est vraiment quelque chose qui nous
habitent c'est une passion pour nous on
pourrait dire une vision des colonisés
oui parce que bon une phrase qui m'a
marqué dans les présentations que j'ai
vu quand je suis arrivé chez vous on
disait que l'architecturé avait été un
puissant vecteur de colonisation c'est
vrai que le conseil de bande ressembler
un autre conseil de bande annonce
première d'une communauté et je dois y
avait pas un souci de représenter la
culture ou les thèmes importants aux
gens des nations dont m quand on se
prenait d'une communauté is a man qui
est je crois oui bien contente de
travailler avec le dit mme ellis je vous
le connaissez alain fournier oui on a
suit des cours de 9,2 tout ensemble
il est quelques années alors je le
connais bien c'est une autre preuve de
son engagement d'ailleurs d'aller
apprendre la langue des gens avec qui il
travaille une raison de plus de se dire
qu'il est vraiment impliqué dans le
travail la collaboration qu'il va avoir
avec les inuit entre autres en fait
c'est pas juste un intérêt de surface
quand on a inauguré la salle joséphine
bacon dans nos locaux oui l'automne
passé
en fait il ya même fait son speech
d'ouverture en innu il a un prix
rappelant nitti toutes nos envies nos
quelque chose est finie t elle perdre et
nous aussi
il a commencé on peut y mettre de
pression parce qu'il a des projets chez
les inouïes on va en parler un petit peu
plus tard mais avant ce qui serait
intéressant de connaître c'est votre
rôle à vous parce que vous l'avez dit
vous êtes chez 22 puis vont presque deux
ans vous avez un risque très précis
pourtant évoque existe depuis 40 ans
mais ces nouveaux quand même qu' une
autochtone d'impliquer à ce point là
mais en fait ils ont vraiment créé le
poste
à partir de nous rend compte parce
qu'ils m'ont approché pour voir s'il y
avait des atomes crochus
s'il y avait une philosophie une manière
de penser qu'ils ressemblent qui se sont
ressemblés est ce qu on n'approche pas
les communautés autochtones comme une
approche une autre qu une communauté
québécois à ce qu'on veut approcher
vendre quelque chose on veut dire donc
il ya un côté développement d'affaires à
mon road de faire connaître la
philosophie des points dans les
communautés et aussi à l'intérieur je
dirais autochtones is et le bureau les
assimiler elle me fait bien c'est bien
commencé mi temps les gros travail est
médiation que le soleil fasse en moins
c'est des fois c'est on a des des fois
on a dit discussion intéressante mais je
te dirais que pas mal à tous les matins
chez heureuse d'arriver à mon travail à
massa c'est une bonne chose alors
autochtones is hell du rousset c'est
bien une entreprise sur wii vont avoir
leur carte
[Rires]
messieurs mais en fait c'est les amenait
aussi c'est accompagner les chargés de
projet des architectes ou tout autre
membre du personnel dans sa
compréhension du monde et première
nation parce que moi j'ai 20 ans
d'expérience maintenant dans cet univers
très intéressant et très dynamique donc
fait les aider un peu plus aussi ne pas
avoir pas de me poser des questions même
s'ils pourraient peut sembler niaiseuse
de me les poser parce que je suis là
parce que des fois on vient de tanis t2
des trajets comme ambassadeur mais moi
c'est un numéro là les internes c'est un
rôle que je remplis quand miley mais
est-ce que vous êtes arrivé chez vous un
peu à reculons
oui oui un recul en jeu là vous parce
que j'étais j'avais des préjugés pour
moi alors obligé mais mes collègues le
savent ils vont l'entendre encore mais
pour moi la profession d'architecte
souhaitait quelque chose de plates et
d'écarter liens de sombres et je me
demandais bien qu'est ce que j'allais
faire leur candidat approcher et j'étais
vraiment surprise de constater quand je
suis rentré dans la firme est comme l a
fait visiter
moi je la compare souvent une auberge
espagnole allez chaleureuse et un joyeux
désordre une belle odeur de café
j'ai découvert parce que je suis artiste
moi même je suis écrivain poète et tout
est de découvrir qu'il ya d'autres
artistes mais en fait des artistes de la
matière de 2,2 comment occuper l'espace
ça c'est un autre un côté abstrait que
je suis vraiment contente de découvrir
chez eux
est-ce que vous connaissiez toutes les
tous les projets mais aussi toutes les
réalisations des votes chez les
autochtones à travers deux pays n'ont
aimons vraiment la prochaine après j'ai
été faire un petit recherche interne
elle est ok j'en ai jamais entendu
parler et par la suite d'en avoir le
site web on comprend le blues qui sont
vraiment impliqués pour noël partout ils
y ont même fait un projet avec un chrono
des britanniques pensent les gens tu
traites 8 mai à dire de le dire dans le
détail pourrait - oui roxanne que
l'apport amène en fait la présence de
maillage et évoque même si on parle
d'autochtones et le bureau l'équipe
c'est sûr que l'un pas qui est vraiment
très très fort parce que ça fait pour
les non autochtones c'est ça fait un
contact privilégié avec une autochtone
tous les jours mes maillots nous amène
beaucoup de de lien avec des événements
avec ce qui se passe dans les
communautés c'est ça c'est très très
fort ça l'est vraiment généré beaucoup
de l'intérêt était déjà là mais ça le
gêne est restée beaucoup des changes les
gens participent beaucoup d'activités
que le maillot met de l'avant puisque
c'est le premier premier aspect le fait
qu'on ait beaucoup plus au courant de ce
qui se passe dans la communauté autant
un culturel que à montréal les jeux dans
les communautés fait que ça ça le c'est
très très intéressant pour tout le monde
puis après parce que ça ne se soit que
maillot aussi elle va nous aider dans
les projets concrètement à mieux
interagir avec les communautés avec
lesquelles on travaille fait que maillot
va nous guider dans la façon de de
communiquer ou parfois vont nous aider à
vous nos coachs et un petit peu là dans
la façon d'aborder les gens d'aller
chercher de l'information beaucoup ça
c'est vraiment pour nous un apport est
vraiment très très près sûr on va parler
d'eux
d'un gros projet sur lequel travaille
encore évoque en fait on semble tout de
suite au nunavut
ce qu'on appelait autrefois cambridge
bay qui a changé non et qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas noté le nom
fallait que je m'en sorte c'est la
station de recherche du canada dans
l'extrême arctique ce qu'on appelle en
anglais de choses
or français je pense est créé à ce
rallye mois de cette station est en fait
c'est notre première fois qu'on la voit
exactement
donc c'est une station de recherche qui
a été créé pour les chercheurs en fait
c'est l'objectif c'est d'amener des
chercheurs du canada mais également de
partout dans le monde à face à faire de
la recherche sur des sujets qui sont
vraiment qu'il touche l'article puis
alizés les installations c'est des
installations à la fine pointe que c'est
ce qui se fait de mieux pour les
chercheurs de différents domaines c'est
aussi pensé pour être flexible donc des
gens qui vont faire de la recherche dans
différents domaines scientifiques
puis le projet dès le départ pris pris
un petit peu une direction qui était de
grâce à l'apport notamment de alain
fourny dans le la mise sur pied du
projet de faire de la consultation avec
la communauté pour s'assurer que ce
projet là arrivent pas la commune comme
un ovni dans une comète rien du tout qui
s'intégrerait à la vie de la communauté
autant par son architecture son site
mais aussi par qu'est-ce qu'ils allaient
offrir comme comme services à la
population locale puis comme occasion
des chambres jeu ok je pouvais oui je
suis en main dessus
moi ce que j'ai trouvé intéressant puis
comment je l'aï compris le projet c'est
que c'est un lieu de rencontres aussi
parce que oui a dit scientifiques
canadiens non autochtones qui arrive là
mais en même temps il ya des gens la
communauté qui sont donc il se demande
qu'est ce qui se passe tu connais qui
peuvent participer à ce projet donc oui
via les consultations en même temps
avoir un lieu de rencontre donc puis se
sont inspirés en fait de l'igloo
communauté malheureusement je prononce
le nom mais oui ce sont expirés deux
sets de 7 à ce qu'on voulait que légende
de la place s'approprient le lieu où ça
se
tout à fait puis il ya peut-être un
point c'est que beaucoup de savoirs
traditionnels qui font déjà partie des
connaissances que la communauté a sur
place donc à travers la création du
bâtiment une réflexion à savoir comment
elle peut battre le bâtiment peut
contribuer à susciter des échanges entre
les scientifiques qui vont venir
travailler à l'endroit mais également
entre les gens de la communauté qui eux
ont des connaissances qui peuvent
bénéficier donc comment le lieu peut
devenir un endroit pour faire de l'
échange de connaissances scientifiques
basés sur les savoirs traditionnels
exactement elie je vous l'avais visiter
un billet vous ayez voulais juste dire
quand j'étais là en reportage au lieu de
trois ans pour d'autres choses c'était
encore su construction mais quand
j'étais avec les gens de la communauté
et on a passé où on avoue le silhouette
de chuck dans le ciel tout le monde est
pointée surtout vers le centre de
partage et puis ils ont dit que ça
s'était inspiré bono et gluck et c'était
vraiment intéressant parce que ça
c'était avec les chasseurs s'étaient pas
avec les gens qui qui qui pensaient que
travailler là et je salue de verchères
mais les chercheurs oui et puis c'était
vraiment réussi une vérité de pour moi
que je sois au courant que leur culture
perfect et d'en acheter 15 heures oui
alors le centre il n'est pas encore en
fonction par contre on y a déjà intégré
dollar 1 c'est le cas et alors même si
ça ne fonctionne pas encore il ya de
l'art et s'étale cet art-là circulent
déjà à travers le canada
grâce à une exposition une exposition et
c'est ce dont vous parliez en ouverture
qui est à saguenay en ce moment oui et
met actuellement depuis un an et demi
déjà circulent qui a commencé je pense
qu'à la gueule à la guilde ici à
montréal
pardon dans cette exposition là de quoi
s'agit-il exactement
mais il faut peut-être commencer avec le
concours pour la public porte charrs
parce que cette exposition n'était pas
conçue pour une exposition pour
commencer et c'était juste par hasard
parce que le concours y est les artistes
inuit qui est soumis le dessin leur
image pour certaines on doit de la
republicca
at choses on voit maintenant ça c'est
une oeuvre 3d de sculpter un coup
décollé de nunavut et on voit pas les
grandes heures de saint jo mais il
m'était décrit que c'était comme dans ce
polar comme six pieds de long
et puis le figure c'est à peu près 3 4
pieds d'eau dowie très très gros mais
toutes les les artistes sont 1200 puis
le jury a choisi l'image gagnante pour
aller dans des différences dans le droit
sow
ça c'était ça le concours les images
étaient choisis et j'ai juste lui
expliquer quelque chose pour le concours
où est normalement ici même au québec il
ya un pour cent du budget est consacré à
de l'art intégrés à des bâtiments
publics
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans au fédéral
c'est pas l'heure c'est ça donc pourquoi
il ya eu un concours alors il trouvait
que c'était important de répliquer cette
politique avait enfin sur le concours
était ouvert les artistes nus est
partout au canada
et puis les images été choisi mais
toutes les dessins étaient toujours dans
le bureau de vote mais un jour il comme
quelqu'un que tu les connais si au
québec connaît andré dudemaine
il est très connu à travers son travail
avec le festival présence autochtone ou
les directeurs cofondateur il était dit
dans mes bureaux 1 journée juste par
hasard et les vues les dessins étaient
tellement frappé par les qualités il le
dit il faut absolument faire quelque
chose avec ça pour qu'il soit comme deux
points plus grand public qui aime jouer
ces images en oui ce serait une idée
oui et puis c'est très heureuse pour
l'animateur de l'art inuit qu' il y
aurait eu cette idée là puis c'est
isabelle lauriers et l'anarchie tech tu
évoques oui mais c'est intéressant parce
que elle aussi bas qu'en donnant
visuelle elle est un artiste visuel
aussi qu'elle a un intérêt très oui pour
juste pour l'art mais aussi la
présentation de l'art et c'est elle qui
était en charge de concours c'est elle
qui était en charge de travailler seul
l'exposition et puis on est rendus
maintenant de voir l'exposition
itinérante et c'est ça donc autant dans
le projet de 1 % au québec il ya un seul
artiste dans ce cas là il ya plusieurs
artistes le viol lorsqu'elle différentes
catégories dans lesquelles les artistes
pouvaient s'inscrire et ce qui c'est
très intéressant et j'encourage les gens
d'aller à saguenay où les prochaines
dates parce que comment ont traduit leur
public dans une exposition
oui mais pour madame lauriers à 17
points ce n'était pas juste que les gens
veulent une exposition est dû aussi des
belles images mais aussi de comprendre
tout le travail derrière ça comment ils
ont travaillé sur l'image selon
l'exposition aussi on voit tout les
dessins soumis par un endroit l'image
gagnante mais l'information sur
l'artiste d'une formation politique
une formation oui l'idée derrière le
site où l'histoire derrière le guidon et
ouais et vous parliez de la difficulté
d'en faire une exposition itinérante
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident parce
qu'il ya aussi entre autres dans les
oeuvres qui sont présentées directement
là bas il ya des oeuvres d'art qui sont
intégrées dans le plancher par exemple
fait pour montrer ça je sais pas si une
photo ont peut-être voir ça tout à
l'heure mais c'est de voir et puis
madame leur idylle dans chaque galerie
où on va voir l'exposition
il faut changer c'est un petit peu pour
pour réfléter l'espace respecter
l'espace de la galerie mais par exemple
à la guilde on a eu comme l'historique
de l'image mais aussi on a une grande
estime
oui cela on voit les images gagnantes
le modèle de l'oeuvre toi dès qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure et on voit comme jeudi à
l'église dit aussi comme les agrandit
certaines portions où les oeuvres pour
que les gens plus la voici le détail
alors c'est une évolution et puis a dit
même dans les prochaines galerie au lieu
de 2 d'exposition
il faut toujours ajusté sont dits peu
pour se pendre l'espace la c1 vitrage du
colloque tv elle est très connue au
canada à travers ses contributions
la collection annuelle de graveurs de
clic de recettes et puis son image été
choisi pour ces grands vitrages là et on
voit les boues qui on veut à droite
c'est très connu pour ses petites images
c'est vrai elle et elle est une des
gagnantes du concours oui les gagnants
pour cette seule exactement ouvert et si
haut si on est un petit lac qui est très
très connu pas juste au canada mais
l'international ces images d'une bulle
ou guettent les poissons étaient choisis
point couloir pour les catcheurs loup
c'est ce qu'on trouve d'ailleurs sur le
plancher exactement et qu'il faut
souligner aussi l'artiste qui vient du
québec
ça me coupe du nunavik et pour lui
c'était son image qui était choisi pour
décrire le plancher dans le centre de
partage
14 c'est très peu de sens que c'était un
artiste neuvic qui est des choisir une
voie semble c'est vraiment beau alors on
l'a dit qu'il avait vu l'année dernière
à la guide de l'exposition
oui c'est vraiment super intéressant
puis c'est un aspect que j'ajouterai
qu'il est assez novateur c'est que quand
les artistes présentaient leurs
propositions il présentait vraiment une
proposition en sachant où est-ce qu'elle
allait aller filmer les gens quand tu
faisais la conception fedex et pourra
les notaires et des sports puis ça s'est
vraiment j'imagine que pour les artistes
sport intéressant aussi de réfléchir à
l'espace dans lequel un rêve dès le
départ allait s'inscrire
oui il faut souligner aussi que gilad
est prévue juste pour trois mois
mais la réaction de la public était
tellement fort que les prolonger pendant
un an
ah oui formidable ça sera pas le cas par
contre à saguenay au centre national
d'exposition parce que ça nous l'hermine
délai 14 avril mais c'est sûr qu'il ya
d'autres dates qui vont être lancés et
puis même les espoirs que ça peut aller
à l'étranger aussi
ok ça pourrait sortir du canada et être
vus ailleurs
on en reparlera si c'est le cas ça vaut
vraiment la peine de le saouler il faut
suivre le site web des votes pour avoir
plus d'informations oui les dates
ça va se retrouver sur votre sim bon
excellent merci lige pour ça là on va
parler des autres projets qu'évoque
réalise un peu partout au canada dont il
ya ce centre de recherches du côté du
nunavut mais on pour aller au nunavik
parce que évoque s'est spécialisé dans
les aérogares
1 c'est ça entre autres projets il ya
des projets on pourrait parler plus
précisément parce qu'on a des
photographies j'espère qu'on les verra
accueillir souk entre autres à quoique
tac et tient 6 août jour je le dis en
gym et c'est en y as oui on les voit
c'est ça qu'est ce qu'ils ont en
particulier ces projets là en fait peut
être exclue premièrement que ce sont mon
travail sur la rénovation des aérogares
d'une avec lui donc les offres village
au nunavik puis à chaque année où à
chaque deux ans en fait on a une
approche soit une rénovation ou une
reconstruction dépendamment des besoins
de la communauté
puis les trois projets venus de l'avant
aujourd'hui c'est des projets de
rénovation
donc le mandat qui nous a été donné
c'est de rénover des aérogares donc la
colonne de gauche ce sont les aérogares
originale la colonne de droite ce sont
les aérogares une fois rénové donc les
villages dont on parle c'est et villages
du nunavik sont seulement desservies par
avion donc et par bateau le pendant la
saison estivale dont et que c'est
certain que l'aérogare c'est la porte
d'entrée de chacune des communautés puis
dans le processus de conception le du
projet dès le départ nous on a travaillé
en intégrant la communauté locale puis
en demandant la communauté qu'est ce
qu'ils aimeraient dire sur leur sur
leurs villages à travers les bâtiments
qu'ils allaient créer qui allait servir
d'accueil aux visiteurs dans leur
communauté
donc pour ces trois exemples up pour les
autres qui ont suivi puis sont en cours
on demande aux gens mais qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez communiqué qu est ce que
vous aimeriez de mettre de l'avant sur
votre communauté c'est la communauté le
cas qui nous revient avec des idées
puis à partir de là l'équipe
d'architectes travail pour essayer
d'évoquer ces idées là à travers les
bâtiments à travers l'architecturé
ultime en hausse à travers l'intégration
des oeuvres d'art qui vont faire partie
des bâtiments entiers donc les trois
exemples qu'on a ici c'est 3
il ya trois thèmes différents qu'ils
aient choisi oui c'est ça si on parle de
celui plus précisément de quoi ctaq on
voulait intégrer un animal vraiment
important dans la communauté
c'est exact communauté qui est le béluga
exact donc quand on a fait cette
approche l'offre auprès de la communauté
les gens qui ont du bénin on aimerait
sans parler des bélougas parce que c'est
important pour nous c'est des chasseurs
donc on a travaillé avec l'idée du billy
kopp et vous le voyez un petit peu à
travers l'architecturé on parle on voi
ces blancs et les formes arrondies on
intégrer des couleurs de bleu un peu
pour évoquer la mer puis l'espace l'eau
dans lequel le belgo évolué puis
rapidement aussi on ne réfléchit à
l'intégration de l'or fait que dès le
départ on a réfléchi comment est ce
qu'on pourra avoir des oeuvres qui
évolue mais également le belgo pas ce
qui m'intéresse en flèche dans cette cet
exemple leur ai dit moi je le mène dans
le choix d'autres présentations
c'est l'idée de collaboration entre un
artis inouk est un artiste québécois en
fait on un chaudronnier
c'est ce qui m'arrivait dans ce cas pff
les seins parce que c'était quand même
toute une pièce a amené parce qu'en fait
que pour les chanceux qui ont été on
voit les sculptures de la mer béluga de
ces petits mais comment on a réalisé
cette oeuvre là en fait ça a été à
partir de l'oeuvre de l'artiste hinault
qui est peut-être lendemain à la base
oui et par la suite a été reproduit en
plus grand parce que le chaudronnier la
sculpter et a martelé le treillis de
lumignons qui est plus léger point à dre
la voilà ça parce qu'en réalité c'est ça
ce qu'on voyait tout à l'heure c'était
l'extérieur de l'aérogare donc on voyait
cette vitre avec les les bélougas mais à
l'intérieur de l'aérogare
il ya cette grande sculpture avec une
maman béluga et c'est petit c'est ça
exactement et par la suite belle
l'artiste québécois voulaient se
débarrasser de ses formes qu'il avait
sculpté le travail était fait mais il ya
des gens qui ont racheté à côté ici on a
une caisse
belga et la collaboration entre les deux
artistes
c'est bien fait oui ça a été ça a été
vraiment super agréable que je vous
cacherais pas que c'est pas facile parce
qu'il faut il ça demande beaucoup de
coordination mais le processus en tant
que tel ça a été super intéressant que
ça a été intéressant pour tout le monde
qui a été impliqué lee comment ça s'est
passé en fait eu un concours dans la
communauté fang la commune auteurs faire
un appel à ces membres puis allemande
est bon parmi les sculpteurs si on
extrait intéressés à nous présenter des
oeuvres
on a reçu on a reçu des oeuvres de
sculpteurs locaux parmi les oeuvres
comité de sélection que choisit les
abris plus intéressant puis par la suite
et un artistes des cantons-de-l'est
collaboré avec l'artiste hinault qui
avait terrorisé pour agrandir comme maya
l'a expliqué les neuf puis pendant le
processus mais il y avait un petit peu
de bakken forte contre les les deux
personnes mais c'est au moment de
l'installation quand les oeuvres par les
oeuvres sont suspendus dans l'espace
c'est à ce moment là que je peux vous
pour l'artiste pour l'artiste la
communauté l'artiste inuit
il était très très impressionné par je
pense que jusque là ils croyaient pas
que ses potes
lui qui rêve de travailler avec une
petite échelle dans la pierre
quand on expliquait que ces bilgo les
volets dorénavant pour lui c'est là
imaginer puis il était aussi
impressionné par la fidélité avec
lesquels elle avec laquelle les hommes
avait été le protêt lambeaux c'est
particulièrement réussie oui alors là on
va partir du côté de hinault joie parce
qu'il centre communautaire qui a été
rénové c'est exact il a été rénové pour
des raisons en fait un peu particulière
de travail de rénovation
mais en fait le bâtiment la communauté
faisait face à un problème de vandalisme
dans le maniement avait été avait été
énormément d'élise et vandalisé pire ils
étaient encore donc quand ils nous ont
approchés c'était la commande initiale
c'est de faire une rénovation
oui bon il y avait certaines choses qui
voulaient modifier pour mieux répondre à
l'usagé auquel la communauté en faisait
puis ils ont parlé d'eux
leurs peurs leurs problèmes de
vandalisme récurrents donc puis aussi
beaucoup de il y avait des jeunes qu'ils
y tenait automne à l'entrée principale
et avait du grabuge qui se faisait
toujours au même endroit fixe compte
proposer comme solution c'était
d'intégrer de l'art à l'architecturé à
l'entrée principale d'une façon vraiment
être très très évidente puis à grande
échelle
puis dans le but un petit peu que ça
soit au flux accueillir mais aussi plus
coloré plus dynamique plus élancé un
noyau l'entrée voilà j'avais l'esprit du
moins vite brisée puis la réaction
initiale
on propose des choses comme ça des fois
si vous aimez l'action c'est sûr que ça
va se faire briser de mettre en oeuvre
comme ceux qui qui qui est d'entremont
peut la toucher d'accès bâtiment puis
bien au contraire on travaille ce qu'on
a fait c'est qu'on a fait un processus
on ait cliqué des artistes font des
murales qui était habitude de travailler
en communauté aux accords puis ces
artistes sont venus dans la communauté
ont rencontré les années la communauté
pour trouver un terme puis on sait
travailler avec les jeunes de la maison
des jeunes allez leur expliquer que ce
cas les phares pourquoi il était dans la
communauté qui allait venir peindre une
murale ils les ont invités à mener
participer s'ils étaient intéressés
ça va complètement changer le momentum
où les gens se sont sentis partie
prenante du nouveau projet oui et puis
justement dans les quartiers des
constructions d'échantillons n'essaie de
on essaie de ne pas avoir de jeunes puis
d'enfants qui viennent traîner autour
des constructions alors que là on les a
complètement changé l'ambiance puis à
partir de ce moment le les jeunes se
sont approprié cette oeuvre le puis il y
en a pas de problèmes de vandalisme 9
ça fait plusieurs années qu'ils doivent
être encore réseau et maya ça c'est une
bonne façon de faire
ben écoute je pense que bien des gens
devront en prendre exemple consulter les
gens écoutent et consulté par groupes
six fautes et les chassa les aînés et
femme les gens prendre le temps
d'écouter ce que les gens veulent parce
qu'on était si longtemps mais aussi lens
on a une belle loi sur les indiens pour
nous le rappeler donc oui
voilà on va quitter les inuit on va se
rendre chez les cris house gbogou où il
ya un projet qui est vraiment
intéressant
en fait c'est un grand cercle avec des
bâtiments publics qui ont été réalisés
d'ailleurs par d'ordre scardino mais la
pièce centrale viennent chez évoque et
oui oui c'est un secret bien gardé
oui on est bien on est bien content un
wii ware en parlait en fait a été
construit en 1989 quand eu la communauté
de djebbour a choisi son site pour se
construire
ben il voulait partir avec un shampooing
donc on connaît l'importance du chapus
one pour les yeux et nous oui aux eyzies
nous aussi on en en chine le nombre
d'annulations
oui on voit la structure qui sera autant
l'hiver que l'été l'été pour les
rassemblements les cérémonies livre de
ce que j'ai compris je crois bien oui
voulant faire une patinoire
donc tout est possible où j'allais je
n'y ai vu de mes yeux vu l'hiver passé
donc c'est impressionnant de l'avoir et
de voir aussi comment après elle a par
la suite inspiré le reste de
l'architecturé comment les maisons se
sont construits les bâtiments importants
donc oui c'est évoquer mon premier mis 7
c'est important c'est moi et on le voit
à vol d'oiseau comme ça c'est magnifique
voir tout cet espace là on pourrait
l'appeler geste fondateur
absolument et là on va aller aussi du
côté des mi'kmaq par sky gas gas gas gas
et bien guillaume gosse cascapédia j'ai
mélangé tout mais mes consoles il ya un
centre de réadaptation aussi qui a été
encore une fois réalisé par eric
exactement en fait on se rappelle dans
les années 1985 86 cas qu'on a découvert
que les i nous en fait les gens de ma
communauté de ma nation in alès
naissance
on se rappelle que ça fait une triste
nouvelle dans les médias on sabre juger
les gens et par la suite il ya eu ce
qu'on ce que j'ai compris un comité qui
avait été créée donc avec des gens des
communautés innues et d'autres nations
pour voir qu'est ce qu'on fait et me
rappelle que monsieur fournier m'avait
dit en avoir fait partie pour ensuite
construire le centre est ce qui était
intéressant à propos de ce centre haute
son esthétique qui est inspiré de la
nation qui les accueille en trop c'est
aussi que au lieu de
les principes directeurs des
gouvernements ben quand qui en fait
l'espace de guérison il ya vraiment plus
écouter les gens qui en avaient besoin
donc les gens des dix nations
autochtones au lieu de ceux de se baser
sur les principes des gouvernements donc
ça c'est un beau geste aussi des côtés
de réconciliation nous inventions de
compréhension une facture et puis le
dernier projet dont on pourrait parler
les tamagotchi nous vite j'y vais j'ai
eu exactement de quoi il s'agit là
écoute moi ce que je peux en parler en
fait c'est que mes gars à moi depuis que
je vois quelqu'un et tout ce que j'ai
remarqué depuis mon retour c'est que ma
communauté vraiment et dynamique alliée
engagée elle bouge beaucoup et là bas
ils ont besoin d'un centre culturel et
sportif
et c'est là dessus que ma collègue
bruxelles travaillent très fort
d'ailleurs il moi je la soutiens peu la
donne en contact avec les gens de la
communauté
oui mais il n'existe pas encore non est
dans les temps de venir et dans les
plats signé d'un plan et c'est un
bâtiment qui loge le la prime de base
c'était une arena donc plus le besoin
principal puis suite à la consultation
avec la communauté différents groupes
donc il revenait à renner puis aussi
envolés un gymnase puis il ya aussi tout
un volet qui communautaire donc une
salle communautaire qui va servir de
lieu de rassemblement pour la communauté
puis certains locaux aussi pour des
groupes comme notable le coup qui sont
très très dynamique et que pour
l'instant le sait jean lempereur leurs
propres locaux dédiés oui donc le
bâtiment rassemble toutes ces fonctions
là à l'intérieur d'un seul bâtiment
multifonctionnel une question concerne
est ce que ce genre d'architecturé et
plus dispendieuse qu'une architecture
occidentale régulière comme on ferait un
gymnase soit une école aujourd'hui dans
une non quelque chose qui devient plus
dispendieux au niveau de la vision
artistique au travers de ce bain en fait
la façon dont on travaille c'est que les
systèmes constructifs c'est les mêmes
faits qu'elle en termes de coûts y pas
de surcoût de parler par exemple 7 2 me
de toi
de fonds d'al khobar d'innovation mais
c'est plutôt de l'eau on va intégrer les
aspects culturels c'est beaucoup comme
dans les formes où on va par exemple
dans ce dans ce projet si on travaille
avec la traditionnelle tournée avec le
jeune étoile exact donc on reprend un
petit peu les volumes blanc les perches
donc c'est pas des choses qui implique
des coûts nécessaires dans ses
ressources matérielles pili volume le
chan couleur fax et des décisions qui
peuvent ne pas entraîner de sortie après
ça c'est certain que si on applique par
exemple des sondages ou des choses ça
prendrait nude et koumisse au départ
quand on fait la conception est une
façon de le faire sans aucune gène her2
de coûts additionnels
alors comme il est en préparation là
comment ça s'est passé les premières
étapes vous êtes allés dans la
communauté vous avez rencontré les gens
la communauté fait parce que la première
première étape c'était définir les
besoins étant quand on nous approcher
les premières fois le projet c'est un
projet d'aréna puis la presse en
disputant avec avec les gens fait la
personne d approcher c'est le chef de la
communauté donc le c'était un aréna mais
on comprenait qu'il y avait d'autres
d'autres sanctions auxquelles le
bâtiment devrait répondre donc les
étapes qui ont suivi sa a été consulté
la communauté puis différents groupes
dans la communauté on a consulté les
jeunes de la maison des jeunes
rencontrés les adolescents on a consulté
les femmes des groupes d'hommes des
groupes de
d'artisanat de gros coussins la
communauté pour savoir mais ce projet
reste s'en vient de quoi est ce que vous
avez besoin est clair à partir de ce
moment là et c'est les gens qui ont dit
ça c'est nos priorités ce n'est pas nos
priorités et qu'il ya des items que si
par exemple dans les idées de base on
pensait que ce serait des priorités la
communauté une fois avoir après avoir
consulté les jeunes ou en groupe non non
non ça on en a pas besoin ont préféré se
concentrer là dessus mais que c'est
vraiment eux qui ont recentré le
programme dieu du projet et que c'est là
une fois qu'on a comme un consensus sur
à quoi ça va servir mais après ça nous
on peut commencer à travailler puisqu'il
était intéressant sur un projet c'est
qu'un exemple des groupes c'est que
peut-être dans la société québécoise on
est peut-être moins une habituée aux
combes et le petit tailleur comme on
appelle souvent des grands mères
oui la pharmacie traditionnelle ligne où
ils vont pouvoir avoir un endroit on ne
rompt pas on a pensé aussi un
congélateur communautaire oui tu es donc
s'il ya quelqu'un on va chasser
je vais aller placer sa viande l'eau
pour en faire profiter les autres masses
alors c'est possible quand est-ce que ce
projet là va être inaugurée savez en
fait les objectifs c'est de commencer la
construction les premières étapes de
construction préparation du site en 2019
d'accord la construction en tant que tel
où on s'attend à voir le bâtiment sortir
de tharsis l'année suivant la queue de
complétion en ou 2021 est ce qu'il ya
une oeuvre d'art intégré au bâtiment
évidemment c'est notre intention est
plus qu'une idéalement parce qu'il ya
quand même des bons artistes mais gare
et connexions dont on espère
oui ça va réveiller la fibre artistique
est-ce que ça fait partie du fameux 1%
d'intégration des oeuvres d'art au sein
des masses hadmar à confirmer en
fonction des sources de financement plus
bas explique oui puis mais une chose qui
est important c'est que dans les
consultations initial avec la communauté
un des aspects que sortie dès le départ
c'était les gens demandent un bâtiment
qui leur ressemble
est ce ça faisait le comfort inn depuis
a apprécié nous ont aiguillé vers
différents thèmes
le shaputuan pourrir et voit qu'à
travers l'architecturé puis
l'intégration de l'art c'est également
de demandes que nous la communauté
donc les gens dont on veut voir à
l'écran dans notre bâtiment des oeuvres
qui font partie de deux futurs bâtiments
d'accord alors parlons-en justement
charme de ce fameux processus
d'intégration en france c'est exactement
ce processus d'intégration le fameux 1%
que quelques cette politique le parle
est ce que ce genre de politique
favorise les autochtones moi je ne crois
pas il reste quand même une grèce quand
même ouvert là vous parlez en général
j'aime pas dans les communes ont pour
laquelle nous je parle en général de la
politique québécoise a dû ministre de la
culture et en plus les artistes reconnus
par le pas ne se reconnaissent pas dans
les exigences de ceux de ce genre de
politique le prince et des exigences qui
sont un peu plus demandons nous si la
réalité la réalité entre les deux entre
les entre entre un artiste à tenir si ce
n'est pas la main c'est en plus qu'à
qu'on veut faire une demande de la
demande se retrouvent entre eux environ
500 autres demandent donc où la
visibilité de la bricole on tait 2,3
autochtone qui vont pour être déposée
par année et puis où le tête avec 400
497 personnes qui ont une chance des
prix aussi confiant que ce soit qu' on
ne privilégie pas qu on ne privilégie
pas dans ceux dans cette politique ne
mais on les met pas de l'avant n'ont
plus cessé ses 6 mais c'est toujours
quand même ils vont toujours quand même
travailler dans cette dans l'idée de du
local on a besoin d'un artiste à
rimouski exemple il pourrait ça pour est
assujetti d'être un artiste de rimouski
dans un lotissement de rimouski est
d'accord justement c'est le temps là
pour les artistes qu'ils devraient faire
partie de ce processus d'intégration des
arts c'est le moment de soumettre sa
candidature
tout à fait on a du 15 février au 15
avril pour soumettre sa candidature qui
est pas une liste en fait là là là
s'appelle la fiche des artistes du
du de la politique d'intégration de
l'art l'intégration de l'art à
l'architecturé l'environnement donc pour
faire partie de cette liste parce que ça
fonctionne par jury quentin immotissimo
de construire ils vont aller ils vont
aller faire une recherche parmi ces sept
banques d'artistes et la wii et un vont
produire une oeuvre avec un artiste
sélectionné pas comment fonctionne alors
que les artistes autochtones
habituellement s'il ne passe pas par le
fameux 1%
ben on va souvent retrouvé déçoit des
organismes comme exemple la ville de
montréal qu'on parle de nos amis qui
vont se reproduire une oeuvre publique
de 1% de 1 million de dollars un ferry
c'est un énorme public vraiment et puis
de ccc des façons c'est je crois que
c'est une demande en fait ça devient ça
devient nous voyons la voix ça se
retrouve ça c'est c'est l'ancienne
autoroute bonaventure bonaventure oui
c'est souvent tueur qui est devenu un
grand boulevard dans le coin de griffin
temps c'est ça et puis bon voilà c'est
ça c'est qu'elle a la chance de pouvoir
produire une oeuvre majeure une des
oeuvres parce que là les pensées il ya
eu une étude qui a été menée par le
conseil conseil des arts de montréal
ils y ont recensé 33 cent quinze oeuvres
publiques dans la métropole de montréal
puis une seule était autochtones
week-end une deuxième qui s'est ajoutée
une deuxième qui s'est ajoutée par l'ami
l'anonymat c'est la troisième armée
diotte avoir omis de mentionner
l'existence du le soyons là voilà c'est
tellement absolument et on voit cette
grande cinéaste alanis obomsawin qu'elle
travaille à creuser depuis la dernière
année on peut voir un intérêt majeur sur
sur le désir public de l'art autochtone
et ce qui est drôle aussi c'est que
l'art autochtone a toujours été un peu
silencieux quand elle est présentement
n'entend pas parler
jeux par exemple du type ils kwakwa quid
de l oubli et nuit et tony hand qui
était père et fils qui en fait qu'on
retrouve sur l'île notre-dame voilà
quatre thèmes
c'est un tel parti qui totalise 12 et
moi j'en fait il a été créé pour l'expo
76-66 resté longtemps mais oubliez oblet
on n'entendait plus parler et respirer
qui a été restauré il a man qui a
retrouvé toute sa splendeur et sa bande
ont pesé comme saint quentin bryce a
refait surface et c'est que c'est
toujours un peu silencieux
donc on n'entend pas parler donc je
pense que présentement une position il
ya un désir aussi de voir l'art
autochtone donc les artistes sont
approchés sont sollicités par des
concours par le biais de concours pour
autochtone par exemple le le pavillon
des arts délicate en
abitibi-témiscamingue or ils ont fait un
concours ont lancé un concours qui
étaient ouverts qui étaient ouverts ou
officier ou fait ch artistique le parc
par le le conseil de la culture et des
communications
d'accord la même dans la même politique
avec la politique était excusé muschick
c est rien le concours est un concours
ouvert à tous en fait oui à toutes les
artistes les artistes non autochtone et
auto partage aussi pour favoriser aussi
la lave autochtones dalle dans leur look
mais c'est quand même le pavillon des
premières nations voyons là ouvert à
tout ça et je pense fait quand même
énormément en entendant parler d'aider
des nouveaux bâtiments qui prennent
place dans les communautés autochtones
ou même en dehors des communautés
autochtones
il ya un engouement de vouloir quand
même garder un esprit autochtone je
pense dans l'arrêt d'un dans leur
bâtiment dans l'eure dans la dcpj de vie
en fait voilà merci beaucoup charles et
on va terminer les missions leur ton
tellement vite
ça va vite un ellis on va rappeler donc
cette grande exposition sur l'art inuit
au centre national d'exposition jusqu'à
14 et pour les gars qui va venir il faut
à consulter le site web blog voilà
et puis le dernier mot vous revient à
roxane et amaya ben moi je fais un appel
en fait aux étudiants autochtones qui se
cherche une carrière vous attendez je
pense qu'on est rendu là au québec
au niveau des premières nations et il
nous est aussi un pion en arène place
pour vous attendre si vous êtes curieux
de savoir c'est quoi larchitecture bien
venez nous visiter
venez nous visiter on va vous offrir un
café un verre d'eau n'importe quoi pour
vous montrer c'est quoi l'univers
et oui comme tu as visité hier a testé
hier la israël où il ya des corps et wii
puis moi ce que je voulais souligner
fait en fait comment mes collègues
architectes chez évoque met de côté un
peu l'oreille aux mais mettre leur
talent au service des communautés
c'est un beau geste d'humilité à tous
même s'ils veulent pas seulement le
reconnaître oui moi j'admire sa de
vouloir permettre aux gens qui ont été
si longtemps est visée de mettre leur
vision à nantes en avant
c'est très gentil très bon mot de la fin
merci beaucoup maya cousineau bolen
roxanne gauthier charlebois cameron
doerksen ellis queen
merci à tous et bien sûr je vous invite
à nous retrouver la semaine prochaine
pour un autre espace autochtone en
direct vendredi à 12h15 à bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]